le seul problème dans cette idée du
grand remplacement de renaud camus et
c'est là où il joue un jeu et d'un
double jeu puisque lui utilise parfois
alors il est arrêté mais dans les années
2010 l'idée de génocide à bas bruit
l'idée d'un remplacement d'une
population par une autre quand même il
veut parler de remplacement c'est
culturel et civilisationnel oui c'est
pas raciale c'est pas la question n'est
pas de savoir alors si de race qui
coexistent vide ne parle pas de
hiérarchie des races mais si c'est une
théorie racialiste pas raciste et
racialiste oui si vous voulez mais c'est
pas vraiment ça qu'ils aient enfin ce
pour lui c'est en quoi la culture
française échangé par les nouvelles
cultures qui arrive c'est pas la
question n'est pas la couleur de peau de
la personne qui est fait c'est surtout
pour lui culture africaine et les
cultures musulmanes qui sont arrivés
frontalement en france dans les 40
dernières années sans qu'on s'en soucie
et sans qu'on prenne le temps d'essayer
les assimilés ou de ou de vivre avec
elle et on a vu récemment avec le
reportage fait à roubaix qu'il ya des
lieux comme ça qui existent aujourd'hui
en france que va dire le contraire qu'il
ya pas d endroit où les gens sont pas
obligés de vivre selon des moeurs qui
n'existaient pas ici avant et qui ont
été récemment importés je pense pas
qu'on puisse se réjouir de ses moeurs
cela qui voile les femmes qui font des
coupes et son visage qui voit les
petites filles je pense que vous serez
d'accord avec moi là dessus et c'est ça
je pense que renaud camus veut dénoncer
est évidemment une partie de l'extrême
droite mais renaud camus n'est pas un
homme politique lui-même a écrit ça
skiable problème c'est comment les
alertes se retrouve face à ce terme là
et comment ils sont obligés de le
reprendre sans vouloir l'assumer
[Musique]